hi there Steve Kaufman here I'll start
out my audio recording um yeah I was
very encouraged to get some comments on
my blog
the linguist on language saying please
do some more videos I thought nobody
cared so I'm going to do one and what I
thought I would talk about and and I
asked on my blog I said what what sort
of videos do people want they want the
general rant so they want the rent on
language learning or they want to talk
in different languages and the response
was kind of like all three so I don't
need much encouragement to continue I
recently put a comment on my blog which
I called five recommendations for lazy
language learners and I said for lazy
language learners which I think refers
to most people so let's begin right
there
most people are lazy when it comes to
language learning and I say that because
most people can't be bothered learning a
language
unless they have some kind of odd they
need it for their job or they need it
for some other professional reason even
those people who are motivated to go to
the store and buy a language learning
book or cassette very often they they
never look at it once they bring it home
it sits on their shelf I know for
research that I'm trying to find a
comfortable position that doesn't have
me too far away from the microphone here
I know from research that attended a
conference in Germany called Parkin
booth languages and professions and
research there showed that the
professional like the corporate language
learner who might have an hour a week of
class with a teacher on average will
spend an hour and a half on his or her
own so that's two and a half hours a
week that is not enough to make any
significant improvement in your language
so so I know that the majority people
are not strongly motivated to improve
the
we didn't so I say they're lazy and I
think most people are lazy given the
choice between doing something that's
difficult and hard work or doing
something that's easy and fun most
people will opt for the latter and
people very quickly say I don't have
enough time and yet I find that if you
have the motivation if you really want
to do it you find the time and so and I
had a question at a forum at Lync on
suggestions to someone who called
himself a lazybones
so from this I came up with five
suggestions for a lazy language learner
which I think as I said refers to most
people the first point is spend most of
your time listening because it's easy to
do you can be listening while you're
driving while you're doing other chores
you can always find time you know while
you're way standing in line at the
supermarket I do I always have my iPod
with me it's not hard work so it's
something that a lazy person can do the
second thing is that once you list and
of course it's frustrating if you can't
understand so as I always say read it
and then you know go in there and find
some words and phrases but don't try to
no learn things don't try to remember
things don't get hung up don't be too
you know type-a as they say about this
just forget it if you forget it you
forget it if you misunderstand certain
things if you fade out it doesn't matter
so that was my second thing the third
third thing was with regard with the
regard to grammar you know get the
smallest possible book skim it every now
and again don't worry about what you
can't remember don't really study it so
I think a lazy person can cope with that
a fourth person first fourth thing was
don't force yourself to speak don't feel
compelled to speak about when you do
just relax and listen and the fifth
thing was don't worry about what you
don't understand about what you forget
about what you're unable to do in the
language just enjoy it
so those are my suggestions in contrast
to the four tasks that I assigned to the
hard-working learner and those were of
course to be much more goal-oriented
more deliberate you know set weekly
goals and stick to them and don't miss a
day in your language learning okay
whereas the lazy guy can go for a couple
of days and not do it right okay I'm too
lazy to write I'm just
working on my Italian my Portuguese and
my Russian having fun with it listening
enjoying I don't write if I wrote I
would do a lot better I'm too lazy to
write but for the hard-working person
right then I say connect with the tutor
because the tutor will get you working
harder even once a week twice a week via
Skype nowadays you can do it you don't
have to get in a car and go anywhere or
take a bus so for the hardware
comparison get yourself a tutor and for
the hard working person review your
words and phrases whether it be in
flashcards or off lists I don't do it
that often because I'm a lazy learner I
prefer to listen so that was my advice
well I get an email or at least not any
no but I get a comment from one of the
people following my blog and this person
says that I have castigated people who
don't have time to spend on language
learning and that he showed it to his
friends and they found a demotivating
here please define lazy you seem to be
stigmatizing learners who can't devote
much time to studying learning a
language stigmatizing and a couple of
people read this on my laptop and found
it quite demotivational he says I'm sure
that that's a word but first of all why
would a person find it demotivating they
either consider themselves lazy or they
don't and I don't think there's any
great sense of stigma attached to being
lazy it's a fact the majority people are
not that motivated to learn languages
and even people who think they are if
they think it's gonna be hard work they
soon lose interest and it's the way the
languages are taught with the emphasis
on grammar and so forth it makes it seem
like hard work
so people quit and so I was trying to
encourage people even if you're lazy
even if you don't want to confront hard
work you can still learn here's how you
do it I don't think there's any stigma
there and I don't see how that can DB
demotivating I think there's a tendency
now that we have to spend so much time
fluffing people up and and and being
nice to them I thought it's being nice
you know you can consider yourself lazy
or not lazy and I made the point that
most people are naturally I think a
little bit inclined to find
easy way of doing things now there is an
easy way of learning languages it
needn't be hard work so even if you're
lazy you can do it put in the time and
as I often say you know it's like so
many other things you find the time
people say I don't have time to exercise
I don't have time to be fit I don't have
the time to whatever might be take out
the garbage once it becomes a habit then
you continue doing it so in summary then
I don't see well like the previous
comment or Chris here he said I consider
myself to an active learner who tries to
learn in the laziest way possible which
for most people would be the most
enjoyable and so yeah I mean I I don't
see where I stigmatized anybody I was
hoping to actually encourage people to
to believe that it's really not such a
difficult and and task it doesn't
necessarily require tremendous
discipline and hard work but it does
require the time this is the point you
can't do well in languages if you don't
put in the time so I again I definitely
agree with Chris's comment here yes put
in the time yes be motivated but fine
and be active but find ways to do it
that suit a lazy personality which is
more enjoyable and that's how you're
gonna succeed and it can you can achieve
success and still study in what's
essentially a lazy way so Charles here
I didn't mean to stigmatize anyone I
didn't mean to demotivate anyone I mean
everything I do here is to try to
motivate people to learn languages I'm
curious if anyone else reacted the same
way
certainly that wasn't the intention all
right this will be my first
Riddhi video rant here after a bit of a
hiatus as I was away enjoying the
sunshine of the California desert thank
you and bye for now